en la mira de las autoridades el
emblemático valen el barrio rojo de
ámsterdam donde las vitrinas Neón
albergan a trabajadores sexuales que se
exhiben ante los ojos de turistas y
vecinos las autoridades quieren
llevarlos a un centro erótico suburbano
Pero ellos se resisten al traslado
lo que personalmente me molesta Es que
la alcaldesa diga que somos solo una
atracción turística y la gente viene a
reírse de nosotras y humillarnos allí en
el barrio rojo
y eso Simplemente no es el caso
creo que es más importante como nos
sentimos que como los demás piensan que
nos deberíamos sentir
valen es una pequeña parte pero también
hay transexuales gays que también
quieren hacer trabajo sexual y no hay
espacio para eso y este centro ofrece la
oportunidad de hacerlo
la agencia Europea de medicamentos que
queda cerca del sitio escogido por las
autoridades se opone a este nuevo centro
los residentes del lugar tampoco los
quieren a su lado
mi hija
Estamos en contra de un mega burdel
porque vivimos en una zona Residencial y
no queremos molestias tenemos escuelas
en la zona y niños muy pequeños y tal y
no queremos turistas como los del barrio
rojo
la alcaldesa quien es acusada de
persecución y de acabar con los medios
de subsistencia de los trabajadores debe
decidir a finales de 2023 la nueva
ubicación
Es realmente difícil complacer a todos
sobre este tema siempre habrá protestas
hay resistencia a cada solución que
elegimos
las restricciones han aumentado en valen
pese a la conocida política liberal de
amsterdam los negocios deben cerrar más
temprano los fines de semana y fue
prohibido el consumo de Cannabis en las
famosas cafeterías de la ciudad